so continue with the afternoon session
next speaker is reveal who's from the
business Casta converse case
Thank You commish thank you everyone for
coming this talk doesn't have any
theorems it doesn't have any technical
content so you can go fish ah hey but
III gave this talk or a version of this
talk a few years ago at a Microsoft mind
swap and I sort of want to revive it
again because I think there's a lot of
you here who could add to what I'm going
to talk about so let me tell you what it
is we think of risk in input data and
computing or while solving problems in
optimization as some kind of a
probability distribution right we think
of it as a calculable gamble right and
how do we deal with these kind of inputs
in our algorithms
what if your input data has a
distribution right well we just do some
kind of average case analysis right
stochastic optimization we assumed the
input as a certain way
in fact I guess all the Bayesian type
stuff in game theory can be thought of
as you have an idea about the
distribution and you're trying to find
an optimum all right in computer science
we think of uncertainty which is some
kind of totally unknown like things are
coming without any distribution you
don't really have an idea
and for this we have and I couldn't find
a better picture we have worst case
analysis so we do you know approximation
algorithms we do competitive ratio right
so the story was I I was at a workshop
several years ago in the Aladdin project
and I was working on approximation
algorithms and in this workshop there
were lots of our people from
Transportation Institute and Georgia
Tech people who work in companies like
Schneider logistics and all that they
were doing we're looking at stochastic
inputs right so then I got on that
bandwagon and I I sort of tried to write
a few papers on stochastic optimization
so I wrote a few papers on stochastic
whatever Steiner tree isn't bad and I
always got these two complaints people
would say worst case analysis is just
too pessimistic you're focusing on this
one
input which is the worst case and you're
designing your algorithm for it right
and when I did any kind of stochastic
analysis people would say how do you
know the probability distribution right
this is too optimistic like it's you're
assuming something that you don't know
about the input data right so that's
when I started thinking so what could I
tell these guys you know I could only do
one of these two and what could I tell
these guys so well I went and looked and
there are what I could find three
possible responses in the literature
okay and let me I'll go through this
this is basically my whole talk okay
so one thing I found that many people do
is they relax the best
of the worst case input okay and many of
you probably already thinking of
examples where you restrict the worst
case input scenario that's faced by the
algorithm in some way or the other right
the other thing you could do is you
could temper the optimism you could say
yeah I don't really know the
distribution but I can make it work for
a larger class of distributions right so
hyper parameter is like you know
distribution over distributions things
like that right I've seen several
approaches to try this have it all
approach what does I have it all
approach I want to build the algorithms
that do the best of both worlds
you know the pessimistic world of
worst-case analysis and the stochastic
world of the optimistic input and what
I'd like to do I'd like to you know pick
your brains on and think about is can we
build a version that's distinct from
these three in the following way I want
an input model right just like
stochastic or worst case which
interpolates between these two extremes
and it has a lever in it so when I set
the lever to one end I get I recover
worst case when I set it to the other
and I get the average case all the
stochastic input and at the same time I
want to derive I want to use this model
to try to derive an algorithm which if
it knows the value of this parameter
where it's set between zero and one that
can also smoothly interpolate between
the performance of the best worst case
algorithm and the best average case
under on the stochastic other okay so
let me try I'll build up the case for
this model
I'll show you specific case of this
model and then I like before that I like
to go through these examples quickly
okay and then I can tell you how it
might be different from what I'm talking
about
okay so this is where I am the next
section I'm going to talk about a set of
papers there by you know you know if
they're basically incomplete and really
representative of the points I'm trying
to make okay so you may have a lot of
related work in this area but you know
please bear with me okay
so relaxing pessimism we know lots of
exam
almost any example of an algorithm that
works on restricted classes of inputs
like you know boundary with graphs or
bounded gina's graphs right this is an
example of saying okay I don't have to
be really so pessimistic you know I'm
going to get something slightly better
okay so that's like a very simple
example of relaxing my pessimism a
slightly related one is well on my
pessimistic corner right I'm going to
make it slightly optimistic by throwing
in a little distribution okay and what I
get is smooth analysis right so I have
this really bad instance and I throw a
little perturbation around the bad
instance okay and then I'll ask what's
my expected performance in this case
running time right over that
perturbation of the bad instance and of
course I'd like to make it polynomial in
terms of not just problem size but also
variability of the bad instance okay so
I would think smooth analysis is really
a way to try to get at this pessimism of
worst-case analysis and in fact you know
one of the very popular results from
smooth analysis is the expected
polynomial time of very good algorithms
like like LP like the simplex algorithm
for LP right so in some ways I don't
really think of this as meeting my need
because I think this approach is really
about explaining the unreasonable
effectiveness of some algorithms which
are very popularly used but how this bad
worst case bomb okay so it doesn't help
me out so much in the case of trying to
trade off between interpolating between
worst case and average case okay so
that's why this is great but this is
like an example of something I want to
think about well there are a variety of
papers on trying to temper optimism now
I'm I start with stochastic programming
so I start with a stochastic programming
model right and then I say look I'm not
really interested just in expected
performance maybe I'm interested in how
bad it can be 5% of the time right and
so for example the guys in financial
optimization call this Value at Risk
right so they you can throw all these
kind of risk measures on top of your X
optimization function right so that you
you're not being like so optimistic
about expectation
you're being were you worried about that
tail end of your expectation okay so for
example this is a paper by one of your
new students I think yeah Antoni
munch also I think and Zang so you know
you can introduce a measure into
stochastic optimization that makes it
look more like worst case okay and in
some sense you can tweak the parameter
in how you are skewing
the portion of the expected value that
you're looking at so that when you where
is a parameter to the logical extreme it
really becomes like worst case from the
set of all possible scenarios in the
stochastic optimization problem okay
so again I'm not defining these things
very carefully but I think the idea is
that don't take expectation take some
tail tail value okay so that's a really
great idea for trying to you know build
as labor okay well we have this whole
sort of field of what's called
distributionally robust optimization it
was started by scarf I think maybe even
before that when he introduced this
famous new swender problem right he said
I only know the mean and the variance of
the demand for the news vendor I don't
really know what distribution was coming
from right so there and he introduced
the idea of a hyper distribution like
take any possible distribution with this
mean and variance and tell me how bad it
can be right when you optimize so that's
another example like the coherent risk
measures of trying to figure out how I
can you know I can move towards being
you know little more pessimistic not
just assume the whole distribution away
okay and there's there's lots of papers
after that particularly by
and later you know but simmers in in you
students and so on okay
so right so I'm just building up the
case of examples of tempering optimism
now there's more papers I think shipra
has one with in you and I mean on niche
hang on correlation robustness so sheer
again the idea is you know the
distribution that's coming at me right
I'm assuming it's like it could be
fairly complicated it could have all
kinds of correlation among itself right
but I'm not going to worry about it what
do I lose so they measure this thing
using something called correlation gap
okay
these are ideas of trying to you know
get out of this right now now let's go
to the have it all the third the third
bucket okay the third bucket of
approaches is there are these universal
methods so the probably the most famous
example is I want to give you a solution
to the problem you're trying to solve
the optimization which is very good for
like almost any input you can give it so
in some sense I don't care about the
space of scenarios right you just I'll
just give you this one solution you
specialize it to your input and it'll
work reasonably well and this example
here is that of a space-filling curve
right in the Euclidean plane and this is
a really good universal solution for the
Traveling Salesman problem in other
words you give me any set of nodes in
this space filling curve right
the space-filling curve gives me a
permutation like a walk through all of
these grid points right if I take the
induced ordering on that space-filling
curve between these points it gives me a
log n approximation to the best possible
TSP solution that you could have
computed with a lot of effort offline
okay so this class of algorithms
basically just forgets about the input
it says you know for all possible
reasonable input subsets in this case
right I'll give you one algorithm okay
now if you think about it there are many
algorithms like this like for example we
have robust algorithms and we have
incremental algorithms I'll tell you
what these are most of you probably know
this already a robust algorithm is one
where I give you one universal solution
and then after I give you the solution
you decide what size you want okay and I
just take the prefix of my solution with
that size and it'll be close to the best
possible for that size so as an example
if I gave you a weighted graph and I
want you to find a maximum matching with
K edges in it okay what would a robust
solution do this was a paper by haseen
and Rubinstein they would give you one
maximum matching of size M over two
right and you pick your K they'll take
the top K edges and it would be like a 1
over root 2 approximation to the best
maximum matching of size K okay in fact
it's actually the maximum matching that
maximizes the sum of the squares of the
weights that has that property okay so
that's an example of a kind of a
universal robust algorithm okay
so I don't have to care about the
distribution I just can I give you this
stuff and you pick what you want to do
this is idea of an incremental algorithm
this is again very similar to this where
you know I want to solve the comedian
problem I don't know what K is yet but
I'll just give you a permutation of the
of the facilities so that you pick the K
then I'll give I'll take the first K
mediums in my permutation and it would
be like an eighth approximation
algorithm for the best comedian problem
for that k so in one swell soup I've
scooped I've kind of got on all of this
solutions in one shop ok so these are
examples of havitol algorithms ok now ok
now I'm going to move from have it all
towards something that's closer to what
I'm trying to do which is best of both
ok what is best of both best of both try
to trade off the two extremes if you
think of the two algorithms that you're
working with as a pessimistic and an
optimistic extreme right the best of
both a guru tum' in this case this is a
definition from this paper by mod Jung
Nasser's a day and I mean sorry it says
if you give me a pessimistic algorithm P
and an optimistic algorithm or for a
minimization problem I'll call myself
gamma P gamma or balanced with respect
to the algorithms P and O if my
value think of it as objective function
value on an input is at most gamma P
worst and the pessimistic algorithm and
at most gamma Oh worse than the
optimistic algorithm okay so this is
again an attempt like suppose think of P
and O as being the worst case and the
stochastic algorithm right you're trying
to simultaneously meet both of them but
what I want you to be careful about or
room note here is that your performance
is not with respect to some kind of you
know offline or best possible solution
to the instance you got it's with
respect to two algorithms that you're
trying to trade off between so your
objective function is actually your
target it's not the best solution to the
problem or the instance it's actually
the best performance guarantee given by
some pair of pessimistic and optimistic
algorithms okay so that's an example and
a for example gave you think of gammas -
they give a - come on to balanced
approximation algorithm for you know for
a resource at a very general resource
allocation framework in this paper so
for example for online Steiner tree
right the pessimistic algorithm could be
the or generalized Steiner tree even
pessimistic algorithm could be like log
n approximation for for the worst case
right and some kind of optimistic
algorithm could be something where you
know the distribution and you get a
constant and these guys will try to come
within factor of two of both of them
okay but it's only with respect to those
algorithms right they're not saying
anything about like the optimal solution
for some hybrid input right so that's
the thing that I I'm trying to fix in
this definition alright more we have
seen papers on Adwords okay I'm sorry
I'm not really defining the problem here
but this is like an online bipartite
matching algorithm right and we know
that the the ranking algorithm this
random permutation algorithm has a 1
minus 1 over e pessimistic guarantee
okay that's the worst-case guarantee and
there are several rival models where you
assume randomization for example the
random arrival model where you
can come within 1 minus Epsilon okay
under some mild assumptions okay there
are these papers of Devon or Hayes and
several others after that okay and this
paper again recently from Bob Merrick
nee Cheyenne and Zod Emolga damn they
again say explicitly in this paper we
design algorithms that achieve a
competitive ratio better than one minus
one over e on average while preserving a
nearly optimal worst-case competitive
ratio ideally we want to achieve the
best of both worlds that is design an
algorithm with the optimal competitive
ratio and both these arrival models okay
we achieve this for unweighted graphs
but they show lower bounds that you
can't do this for weighted graphs okay
so this is another example of an
algorithm that's trying to achieve best
of both okay looking at the pessimistic
in the optimistic all right what else
I've got I've got one of Alexander I
guess isn't here yet and this is one way
they try to do it for bandits okay I
guess here the bounds are about regret
there are regret bounds okay it's a
different measure okay it's not the
traditional approximation measure I've
been talking about so far
and again they're trying to combine the
worst case regret for adversarial
rewards and a poly logarithmic regret
which is much better when you know the
input and it's stochastic okay so I
think I've given you a good example of
the type of things that are out there
that are trying to trade-off worst case
and stochastic inputs okay I'm sure
there's probably lots more that I hate
that I missed I'm thinking there's
probably a lot of these types of
algorithms many of them more in in games
algorithmic game theory there's probably
a lots of these these models are tried
to do this trade-off that I missed and
maybe others also in fields that are not
really computer science but are more
firmly rooted in stochastic inputs like
statistics or like anything I missed
particularly yeah
you're so the problem with defining
optimal is what is the input model
that's like a universal algorithm right
so I'm just trying to define you're
absolutely right if my problem is easy
to solve right under so okay so I guess
I'm actually confusing two issues here
so I have to be careful okay suppose
it's a static problem okay so I'm just
going to get this one input and I'm
going to run it through the algorithm
and solve it right and if the solution
method is easy for any input then I
don't care whether the input comes
adversarially or stochastically right I
don't see any deterioration and
performance between the two extremes but
it could be the case the algorithm it's
the problem itself is easy but when the
input comes say one by one online that's
true so you're absolutely right yeah the
trading off is only an issue when I see
a noticeable deterioration and quality
in going from a very good stochastic
input model to to an adversarial model
where I don't know what's going on yeah
so that's that's really a great point
yeah it's this is only in the case of
quote/unquote hard problems any other
comments or observations any of you it's
all related that's why I mentioned
algorithmic game theory because they're
also trying to bridge the gap between
the stochastic Bayesian type world of
the micro economists and our prior free
world and Suchi yeah because what you're
saying is that if you were in the
stochastic world then there's a class of
algorithms that is optimal and
in the worst case you compete against
that class of all algorithms which is
different from saying that you're sorry
for right it's it feels more like the
best of both worlds like you're trying
to compete against the best in class the
best in class in both worlds that's what
I feel okay so let me give you my
suggestion maybe totally stupid and many
years from now I'll watch this video and
say why the heck did I give this talk
okay but you know for what it's worth
okay I have ten minutes thank you okay
so my idea is we should build a model
which interpolate smoothly between these
two extremes okay and just just what I
think could be useful if you had an idea
about how inaccurate your estimate is of
the of the optimism or the pessimism
okay then maybe you should be able to do
better algorithm again I'll give you a
specific example okay so the two things
I'd absolutely want in my new model is I
want a lever that does this
interpolation and I want the algorithm
which when knowing where the lever is
set should interpolate smoothly okay so
you'll you'll you'll generate an input
and you'll set a lever okay and you'll
tell the algorithm sure is the
stochastic input and here is how I've
set the lever okay
and the algorithm based on where the
lever is set would match the best
guarantee possible in particular at zero
it would give me the best possible
stochastic algorithm at 1 it should give
me the best possible adversarial
algorithm and it between it should do as
best as it can so let me go on without
further ado and take a particular
example which is well studied by the way
all of these thoughts really arose in a
Aladin REU that I did with guy block and
kadar and Suppan who was an undergrad
and she did a bunch of coding for this
ok so the problem is something that most
of you know it's list update and I'm now
doing online even though you know we
could ask the same thing of some
straight one short optimization problem
ok and I'm going to just try to motivate
my hybrid online model and I'll if I
have time I'll show you some
experimental results but it's not
important ok so the problem is clear I I
have a list of credit cards in my wallet
ok they are in some order I get a
sequence of requests where I need to use
one of
my credit cards okay and the cost of
accessing the element is I have to walk
down the list and it'll cost me I steps
but once I get it I can put it anywhere
in front okay
and at any point in time just because of
my whim I can transpose any two adjacent
credit cards at cost one okay it's a
standard list update model okay here's
an example you know you know for example
here I have accessed X it took me four I
accessed V it took me five and then I
just decided on of them to move it to
the front okay
the total cost is nine and then after
that I access Y okay and it cost me one
and I access V and that cost me two at
this point I could decide to switch Z
and W and that cost me one okay just
just like that okay so this is the cost
model for list update there's a standard
okay
and the what would be an average case
analysis for this problem well we could
think of the card request as coming from
a discrete memoryless probability
distribution I access credit card I with
probability P I and the P I sum to one
okay and you know time after time you
roll arise a roll of dice okay and you
ask for that card okay and I will give
you okay and I could try to minimize the
expected cost right well in the limit
the best thing to do is just keep your
cards in the sorted order of requests
probability right well if you can't
quite keep them if you don't know P I
right you could just kind of count
frequencies and figure out whether you
know what the right thing is then you'll
sort of converge in the extreme okay and
you know the static one never sorts
anything it's just it never moves
anything it just leaves it like that and
this is actually a great algorithm when
we have the estimate if someone told me
what the probability distribution is
this is probably a pretty good solution
right and like I said if you didn't have
the distribution you just use frequency
counts okay and you'll keep the list
locally sorted according to the count so
far right and all of you know what
competitive analysis is I'm comparing
against the optimal offline algorithm
I'm allowed a little extra constant and
the famous early competitive in fact the
first competitive analysis result was
by slater and arjun which is for this
simple move to front heuristic which is
whenever you access a credit card put it
in the front of the list okay
and they prove that it has a to
competitive performance there is no
matter what the input sequence is no
stochastics here okay it's at most twice
the number of great okay actually if you
just maintain the status the static the
if you if you're comparing yourself
against the static list right then in
the extreme just doing frequency counts
and updating is great you know it'll
converge to one okay this is what ron
rivest proved okay and then there was
this analysis by chung hijae lon
seymour which said even if you did move
to front okay your expected performance
ratio than expected cost with respect to
static is PI over two that's one point
five eight okay so then Suzanne yeah
right right here right trying to do
something like this trade-off okay
Suzanne and Mike okay they said look we
what we are motivated by presenting a
universal algorithm that is good
competitive ratio but it also performs
well when it's generated by via
distribution so in in our words it's
sort of the have it all bet of best of
both worlds approach okay and just what
they showed well first of all what is
timestamp timestamp is a deterministic
algorithm okay suppose you've got a
requested item X okay put it in front of
the first item in this list right which
was requested at most once since you
were last requested so one way to think
of it is you have you been requested X
look back in time until the previous
time X was requested okay and in the
time window see who else was requested
less than you at most once okay now you
just walk down the list and put yourself
in front of everybody like that okay so
it makes total sense it's sort of like a
local frequency count
and so this is the time stamp algorithm
that Suzanne suggested in her soda 95
paper okay
time stamp is too competitive so it it
it's actually as good as moved to front
right and the expected performance of
time stamp with respect to the stat he
is better than pie over two not only
that that previous algorithm what was it
move to front right actually has a worse
performance ratio in the expected sense
you see in this sense time stamp is
strictly better because it's at least as
good as move to front in the worst case
and it's actually better in the expected
case with respect to stat okay so I
guess we're all this is sort of the
punch of these this result okay it is
actually better it's doing better than
okay so what I'd like to do is to add
something to this model and this is the
most important slide you can forget
about everything I said so far okay this
is the simple suggestion okay we have
this fixed distribution according to
which our credit cards are being
requested okay in stochastic
optimization we assumed this is given to
you okay so I assume that you give me
this fixed list okay except that you
really are not giving me this
distribution in fact you're going to
give me a input sequence of some length
and every request with some tiny
probability epsilon you the adversary
will change the request okay so what
does that mean if you've never changed
it I know exactly what you're giving me
if I love you to change it all the time
I'm back in competitive analysis this is
the lever I'm talking about okay and in
between this is the interesting part
where you are telling me what the
distribution is but you're also telling
me how much you're going to deviate from
it right on in this case on a sequence
by sequence yes your bra
Bayesian model where if you you could
model this lever by the prior you can
require to design a prior free algorithm
then I point priors are like your worst
case and uniform prize like your average
correct that does sound like some hyper
like some large distribution and the
point prior is picking one and yeah so
it could be totally related it could
just this could just be an instantiation
of it
okay so yeah I think we have yeah you
shy yeah that's exactly it so I think
what you two are talking about are
exactly this okay so but what do I want
remember my second decider oughtta right
okay
what I want is an algorithm that will be
given P and epsilon and when the epsilon
I gave it to zero it should do as well
as stat or frequency count or something
like that and when the epsilon I give it
as 1 it should do no worse than 2 that's
what I want okay the short of it is I
don't have such an outer room okay but I
have a candidate okay the candidate is a
following so let me say that candidate
and I'll stop okay the candidate so this
is the desiderata the we have the model
but I want this this trading off
algorithm okay which matches at both
ends okay the candidate algorithm is
something we call move from back
parameterize by epsilon which you give
me like epsilon is the is the
adversarial perturbation it's very
simple
keep your initial guess to be the
original probability distribution sorted
order right it's the best initial one
when you access an element you look at
the element before it and see if it has
more than epsilon chance of being
requested more than you in the original
distribution because if it does right
even if I put up the distribution to an
extent epsilon it has a higher chance of
staying ahead of you right it's a very
simple idea
okay so I move from back parameterize by
Epsilon and when I get sort of stuck
against somebody who's got higher like
convincingly higher Epsilon higher
probability I don't promote myself
beyond okay and the short of it that we
found okay there's an example and all of
that but what we found when we are on
experiments by using several types of
input distributions you know zipfian you
know uniform you you name it and several
types of adversaries right the adversity
could be really cruel and choose the
worst guy at the end could be oblivious
it could be uniform it could be reversed
geometric right it always turned out we
got pictures like that where our
algorithm this Purple Line right was
never worse than the worse of the other
two in terms of expected competitive
ratio okay and here I have to be careful
I mean this is an important point so let
me make it when I'm comparing my move
from back or any algorithm right which
is given the distribution and epsilon
what I'm computing is the optimal
offline solution for that distribution
which is bloody hard okay I have to do
it by some expensive dynamic programming
so I could never get beyond 100 sequence
right sequence of size hundred but I
compared the optimal cost versus the
cost of my algorithm right and I
generated many times when I took the
expected value of the ratio maybe that
was bad
maybe I shouldn't all not have done
expected value of the ratio but it
always turned out that our algorithm
seemed better than these tools sort of
the desiderata okay but we can prove
that it's expected competitive ratio
goes between this and this so just to
finish up right the performance really
depends on the type of adversary it
seems to be better than the verse of
stat and move to front okay so our
conjecture is what's called the not the
worst conjecture the average worst
average competitive ratio of move from
back Epsilon right it's not the worst
among the three okay what's probably not
true is that it is the best of all three
okay I don't think that's true but I
think it's not the worst
so in that slightly pessimistic but
somewhat optimistic note I'll end and
take any more comments or questions yeah
they disciplined let's take questions of
mine